[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir voila c'est dingue tu as quel
âge toi qu'à vous me donnez non mais dis
moi dis moi dix sept ans
n'essaie pas de faire de 29
c'est quoi ta maman c'est quoi ton ya
pas de l'âne témoin ses bâtons et jets
la vingtaine non mais dites nous tout
vingt-cinq je sais tu avais des 25 à peu
près 26 sont à
[Applaudissements]
25 ans déjà ringard
moitié de l'année alors parce que je
pense qu'il est tout émoustillé parce
qu'après
venez remettez vous connaissez
pas tous
mais prenez vous la main et venez et
enlevez moi la musique allez vous
apprenez vous la map waliboo la main et
puis vers moi
me plaît comme ça allait donner
l'arrêt de cour
mettez vous ne dites rien je veux les
voir je le confesse voir s'ils vont bien
ensemble et non mélangés à les sorties
c'est ma tournée emballement marché
semaine brunet bulama
il est lourd à l'est
mais c'est pas appris la leçon kieffer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
après les médias ça les codes d'un grand
talent 25
centrales ont donc senti menacé
c'est rocco siffredi
d'après le benayoun la première fois que
j'ai vu mon coeur a fait bondir
la donne en cédant 6 à 7,1
sur vous seriez vous allez vous calmer
on et cyril vous êtes un pro du chef
d'orchestre de cette chaîne ne dis pas
de bêtises il va le faire quand tu fais
le faire quand on le fait maintenant
j'étais bloqué 50 / tu peux lui dire
s'il te plaît il faut lui parler lui
laisse coi madidi kissman le cul ouais
thalassa chez
toi non mais
donc si vous êtes un peu le chef
d'orchestre de cette chaîne vous savez
qu'à une téléréalité qui arrive sur la
grille pourquoi
alors c'est quoi bon mais écoutez moi
vous êtes vous êtes le chef d'orchestre
chaîne de télé réalité qui arrive vous
savez comment ça pas de cette télé
réalité mais tunisien boulbi toi tout ça
pour ça
[Rires]
après les marcil à dubaï le martiaux à
mykonos et les marseillais a marre de la
voici des tunes à bouilhou non
la joie de vivre et la fête animeront la
villa
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais tout risque de ne pas se passer
comme prévu à vous me dégoûte relais
pour qui il ya 20 ans animé une émission
qui a marché 300
le redis ce jour notre corps bonjour
distincts sûreté au moins tu fais
quelques bons d'émission ils le forcent
les castaldi va-t-il mettre à mal
l'ambiance au sein du temps caché
prochaine
descente de secondes à faire du bruit
toutefois que ça bouge dans toi tu mon
pape bénira mois ont permis à sa mère sa
compris entre charreaux et tarbes à tout
sera prétexte à la bagarre a été hier
soir chez elle au parc des princes avec
reno et tu avec une amie il a encore
essayé de pécho la mafia c'est une fois
que je le voyais dans la gamme
au cours des sept saisons incroyables
sept candidats explorera une face cachée
de la lune
une question devenue un terreau les fans
question d'une auditrice
tu bandes
[Applaudissements]
j'aime beaucoup dit yoyo avec lui dans
la voiture une scène torride à l'arrière
de la voiture pourquoi pas oui d'accord
oui ça traverse une période difficile
donc il m'a demandé de venir chez lui
pour le réconforter en tant que potes et
un moment il s'est mis à trembler je lui
ai pris la main et jeudi mais jordan
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour que tu
aille mieux il m'a regardé dans les yeux
et m'a dit busch mali
bon pour résumer sa wacken comme des
porcs
[Applaudissements]
elle est là
à
je vais y montre géraldine
et je bouscule de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
les tunisiens à bolbec c'est seulement
si c'est nier sa chevauchée de l'amitié
cassidy
vous êtes vous prenez jamais restée très
drôle de remonter super
tous un peu j'aime bien cette prostituée
mon espace vital
et psion tbonds vous sentez le cuir qui
vaut cher mais tiens
à te sentir le cul qui l'est
c'est peut-être les 40 ans de cette
tactique pour vous a le plus la dame qui
n'ont pas du tout c'est matthieu
delormeau études alors mostafa mais il
n'a aucun critère de sélection matthieu
delormeau c'est un peu la porte ouverte
à toutes les règles
[Musique]
saissac guen catégorie à chaque famille
sa baby fait ce qu'ils appellent ça mais
bizarre oui c'est tu vas petites choses
que tu va secouer quoi
libe oui bien sûr les connais indices us
et on sait mais c'est pas le moment guy
tour
je mets de l'anti cernes mes potes se
moque de moi je suis là à mettre de
lentilles savez je m'épile sous les bras
pour deux sous et hulot à la paire
dollar-yen
je suis là tu lui poser trois questions
gilles est ce que tu regarde parfois
aussi des films avec des garçons se
tiennent bien définie de la détresse que
tu arrive de lire ce garçon est très bon
ouais non mais j'ai pas pensé à vous
mais j'ai parfois pensé à guy roux
et en quels termes tu peux développer un
petit peu les gens écoutent érotico
cérébrale comme moi je suis cérébrale
plus c'est dur
tu joues étudiants on a parlé de toi que
c'est cette phrase formidable a dit
quand on a eu quatre femmes à et en
cherchant bien sûr
jouer
couleur en plus qui est raté
il demande à son meilleur ami joue avec
sa guitare
il fait une couleur et rendre les toiles
de raymond
si c'était toi et 10,6 et piqué
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est moi qui ai
appris
je veux excuse moi je peux parler april
sûr que tu viennes mettre son grain ce
que
j'aime c'est que j'ai une famille non
mais je peux parler a pris deux coups
sûrs
est-ce que sacha à quoi on n'a pas le
droit non non c'est pas la peine de
poser la question oui c'est non est-ce
que ça chez vous il ya déjà eu quelque
chose hein
[Musique]
vous pensez quoi honnêtement banon dans
son oui peut-être les u11 en bon jour
sur toi au revoir
mais est-ce qu'un jour
quand il a dormi chez vous oui il a
dormi chez elle elle lui a prêté le lit
de son petit frère son lit bébé
[Rires]
après les skins chaude entre ça chez
vous parce que c'est un très beau garçon
oui ils envoient des textos fait voir ça
non je sais je et exemple le pas du tout
je suis en train de s'accumuler preuve
détection des techniques
prend le téléphone d'après le site e p
non est ce qu'il ya un texto de sa
chaîne base pendant tout non non pas du
tout
maintenant j'attends sa valeur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
du tout bon ben moi je crois en a pris
les deux minutes sauf au taps scala et
bien sûr il vous avez raison il n'y a
jamais rien eu entre sasha et moi c'est
pas ce que dit sachant pas ce que dit ça
on est d'accord j'aimerais qu'on crève
l'abcès sachez raconte à qui veut
l'entendre en coulisses oui il a fait
chaud april non non je dis pas ça je dis
caprine madrague et non tu dire ce qu'il
a fait il a demandé un stagiaire d'aller
acheter son parfum pour mettre sur sa
veste pour faire croire qu'il l'a fait
chaud c'est un dangereux mythomane
j'ai les preuves sérieuses et graves
j'ai des preuves je sors mes messages
avec april non mais laisse tomber à sont
là qu'est ce que je lui ai dit
c'est fini entre nous a pris les grands
moyens mais ça
mes frères mes jeux là des vannes mai
2009 170 maisons connues n'ont pas du
tout en asie a défait de dernier
magnétisme et
mythomane je suis
en fait je vous n'aimez pas l'amour vous
mais non plus
pas du tout mais pas du tout aller qui
gêne tout le monde
d'accord je suis quoi je suis trop match
pour april
simplement pas envie d'attraper un
lumbago
c'est quoi cette fois c'est qu'ils
apprennent d'automne encore non non non
mais c'est mentalement tu as encore un
peu importe cette jeune femme mais les
gens ont besoin
d'eux en mal et très mature une façon
c'est pas la question je suis prêt à la
propriété prêt ou
avec ce petit personnage ce petit barbus
les paquets s'il l'était ça sera pas au
canada
[Applaudissements]
gladiator ça serait pas avec un bouquet
comme mollo est parti
c'est moi qui lui apprit fanni
se serait pas non plus caché
qu'est ce qu'elle m'a dit ça leur a pris
non je dis alors je le dis comme ça tu
fais comme ça guillaume aime dit non
jeudi mathieu aime dit non castaldi m
dit non julie et sasha m10 elbaz à el
baz
[Applaudissements]
allez vas-y locéryl vous savez je suis
un [ __ ] petit fouteurs de manière ce
que tu habillé comme un gipsy kings
combattre
certains loyers pas du tout
cherché une belle veste et cherche à
aller dans votre placard m'a dit c'est
le show petit fouteur de merde
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est l'animateur du mag mcc a plongé
nrj 12 qui
a présenté au final vous finalement
fosse était le fils de gilbert d'être là
parce qu'on est en retard c'est vous
avez chanté fouteur de merde depuis
plusieurs semaines je prends quelques
heures sur lesquels vont me rémunérer
d'ailleurs pour faire les petites
canular les petites galéjade cette
semaine j'ai pris la voie de nikos et
j'ai envoyé sur what's app j'ai changé
ma photo de profil et mon nom des
messages a déjà voilà aiko pro celui-ci
comprend 6 6 me j'ai demandé à nikos de
rabais parce que c'est que nikos est pas
content parce que matthieu delormeau
arrive demain avec une émission people
en face de lui cyril rooney
mais si vous comprenez nikos et colère
non il n'ya pas de yao kouman vous allez
voir c'est parti j'ai pu les gêner riam
avec la boyne écosse et pas que
d'inviter simple idée qui revient
[Musique]
oui comment ça va saigner cause des
dégâts sur téléphone
bonjour pascal
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la bête
comment ça va
je sais pas si c'est vous qui vous
occupez de la nouvelle émission de
l'ormeau
annonces sur les people
parce que je vois beaucoup excellent
savoir si vous êtes et chroniqueuse de
dos
je crois que c'est produit par portons à
messieurs je
vois que c'est matthieu delormeau
wit est un passage en france rien ne
peut pas pousser sur les jambes
je voudrais faire un petit portrait de
toi dans 50 pays inside est invité pour
boîtes à coach supplémentaires dont de
voice ça te dit au mois d'avril un peu
près
avec confessions j'y suis ouvert à tout
je voudrais que tu sortes un petit peu
tu pousses un peu lâche enterrer son
mari devait du coup
tu ne pas chanter un petit peu pour le
russe
on a les clés du coffre un répertoire
et pas question pour moi de chanter
parce que justement nous nous pousser à
sur saône est un petit peu un petit
refrain
[Musique]
tu pourrais juste trois secondes
un petit gag pour touche pas à mon poste
de télé cet ep est un peu touche pas à
mon post hausse
[Applaudissements]